so I think that the solution to the hard
problem of Consciousness I suspect is
not going to be very
interesting I suspect that the solution
to the hard problem of Consciousness
will be Consciousness just is it's a
quality that emerges when matter takes
on a particular organized form and under
goes certain very orderly and organized
procedures and phenomenon and if that's
the answer and I think that is is likely
to be the answer then count me out in
terms of wanting to solve it I think
that may be the solution if it's more
interesting than that if there's some
Consciousness field that you know
various religions talk about or or
something that we can't even imagine and
that's the root of Consciousness yes
then I'd love love to be part of the
journey to solve it that way